you know
the problem is and you know i don't even
know how to
do this with the internet i know how to
do this in a conversation with human
beings but i don't know how to do it
with with the internet because you have
to fear
the editor right what the editor is
going to do with what you
say is potentially going to overwhelm
any point that you can make and that's a
tragic lesson when i learned in college
the first time and keeps getting
reinforced
but obviously you need
mark twain for example in order to
understand
race in america because he gives us a
snapshot and he gives us a very humane
snapshot but it is not a snapshot devoid
of what we now call the n-word
and if you want to cancel that book
because it contains a word that you've
now been told that any white person who
utters it
is guilty of a crime well now you've
just
robbed us of one of the greatest tools
we have that's right
um likewise and you know
maybe my favorite song ever is hurricane
by bob dylan from 1976
it is for those of you who don't know
and i really would invite you to go
find it and listen to it carefully right
it is a story
of hurricane carter reuben carter who
was
falsely convicted of murder in a deeply
racially biased
court system right so the police and the
courts conspired against him
and convicted him of a murder that he
had not committed
and the song is blistering
right it is an absolutely blistering
attack on the system that did this
and it is also um it is not an over
overly analytical song it is a song that
um indicts the humanity of the people
involved in this crime and humanizes
reuben carter who
we have been led to believe we in
civilization have been
led to believe is a bad guy who did
something bad and that's why he's been
locked up
so anyway that song contains
i hate that i have to say the n word
here right
but i don't know how else to do it so i
don't get edited to that one
sentence and it'll be about one word you
know i'll find video of me uttering that
one word
out of context and suddenly the ability
to say here's what i was saying i was
quoting bob dylan i was quoting bob
dylan in a song
in which he is revealing what again i
don't think this is the right word but
he was revealing
what we now would be told is white
supremacy
right a system that is systematically
indifferent
to the interests of black people right
he goes through it he explains he
actually details not only
the circumstances of the the crime and
the investigation
but the bad witnesses and their perverse
incentives and the structure of the
court that carter finds himself facing
the whole and the press i mean he goes
through the whole thing it's just
it's a tour de force and the point is
you you want to rob us of that
you want to rub your kids of that you
want to explain white supremacy and not
have that as one of the tools in your
toolkit
right the song actually um instrumental
in getting hurricane carter released
absolutely yeah yeah so the point is
like this is how it's
done people right it's done narratively
and it's done unflinchingly and it is
not the stanza and just not i mean i
understand why you don't want to say the
words i i i it is
frankly against my religion okay to do
it and say
n-word because for one thing it
interrupts a rhyme that's important to
the whole thing
the rhyme is obvious though yeah well
okay so this stanza
i know it by heart but can i do it in
front of the camera
um let's see it was um
oh to the white folks who watched he was
a revolutionary bum and to the black
folks he was just a crazy [ __ ]
nobody doubted that he pulled the
trigger and though they could not
produce the gun the d.a said he was the
one
who did the deed and the all-white jury
agreed
i mean that's beautiful poetry yeah
right and it is a very ugly word
and it has to be there in order for that
piece of poetry to work
yeah i think you probably couldn't have
called it up after
uh after saying the word if you would
replace it with n word there
right you would you would have lost your
place i would have lost my place and i
would have been heartbroken that this
important tool had been made dull i mean
yeah
what do you do so look and i mean just
like
it's obvious it's obvious
that this is not a word that you are
trying to use i have no need of that
word
to use in earnest but sometimes there's
a need to discuss its use in twain
or to discuss its use by dylan or to
discuss
its modern use you don't you need
discretion
and you know you have to the only way a
system can work is if you have
discretion to decide where use is
legitimate and where use is illegitimate
and you know what
you're probably even going to have to be
generous because even if you
say well twain is a legitimate case
dylan is a legitimate case
most cases are illegitimate and that's
true they're going to be some gray area
cases
right i mean in fact who was it this
woman who just got cancelled for
wearing blackface while mocking
uh who was it the uh the juror the
the talking head on tv is it megan kelly
is it megan kelly
yes we should know mocking her when in
fact what
she had done was say something super
clumsy
but you know she she had said something
super clumsy about black faces she's
trying to navigate something
that's my recollection anyway and then
somebody
makes a halloween costume mocking her
for her tone deafness on this issue
and you're gonna ruin her life over this
i mean
yeah even if it's an error it's not an
error of some
you know profound rot at her core it's
an error
now we've talked about the death of
empathy it's also the death of satire
yeah right again the tool you would want
most prominently at this moment in order
to sort out this really difficult stuff
you're going to rob us of satire
that must be because you have an
objective that involves power and if we
can satirize stuff if we can laugh at
ourselves
then you won't get there
you